l'étude du projet de loi 16 se poursuit
en commission parlementaire à québec
projet de loi qui a pour objectif de
réformer la loi sur les copropriétés
cette loi était adoptée en 1969 et
aujourd'hui c'est près de 12 % de
ménages québécois qui vivent dans ce
type d'habitation alors pourquoi c'est
nécessaire d'adopter une réforme
yves jolicoeur est avocat émérite du
cabinet de grand prix jolicoeur
fondateur également secrétaire général
du regroupement des gestionnaires et
copropriétaires du québec bonsoir
monsieur jolicoeur qu'est ce qu'on doit
changer
exactement et qu'est ce qu'on va changer
en face il y aura une vision du futur le
coup propriété et 5 en vendant son a
commencé créé la compétiton n'avait
aucune expertise aucune vécu contrat
malheureux et 50 ans plus tard on
réalise que beaucoup de bâtiments qu'on
allait réagir quand 25 30 ans ont mal
vieilli
faute d'entretien bien souvent faute des
mots parce que les gens pensent que
vivent cobol-it et c'est un peu comme
vivent à l'hôtel par le législateur est
venue de la forme créer un plus grand
cadre pour l'un pour la formulation et
la gestion efficace des immeubles en
copropriété me dire quoi la gestion
efficace et j'assume efficace c'est
peut-être de prévoir en amont comme une
voiture un carnet d'entretien plusieurs
imams aucune car les entretiens de
rebâtissent manon qui ont aucune idée de
comment on peut planifier des travaux en
amont une fois qu'on les a planifié
qu'on établit également des budgets
conséquents parce que souvent des
budgets qui était dans le fond on peut y
réaliser sans écrite et on va commencer
de l'entretenir et ultime à prévoir les
dépenses futures en termes de
réparations majeures
qu'est-ce que drame de remplacement des
particuliers donc ça veut dire que les
gens qui sont en copropriété doivent
mieux prévoir et mettre plus d'argent
dans le fond très voyante mieux prévoir
mieux entretenir les bâtiments on a
souvent
on dit souvent des fois encore it et que
ça reste un régime qui déresponsabilise
les gens on pense que quelqu'un s'en
occupe de korité alors que donne à des
gens qui sont bénévoles de bonne foi
qu'on peut toujours des compétences à
l'idée de ce nouveau système législatif
s'est créé dans le fond plus de
professeurs disent relativement à la
gestion de copropriété donc plus de
professionnalisme ça veut dire peut-être
la formation pour les gestionnaires de
copropriété de l'information aux
gestionnaires à noter qu'ils soient
reconnus par la loi le pour l'instant de
projet de loi 16 contrairement à
l'ancien projet de loi qui a été déposé
par le ministerio ne prévoit rien sur
l'encadrement des gestionnaires donc un
peu d'info copier le système enterrés ou
les gestionnaires doivent être à fond
encadrer former aaron viles à fond dans
comme de revendications un meilleur
contrôle de ses ça c'est pas dans le
projet de loi pour l'instant ce n'est
les portes d'un projet de loi pour est
mais ça pourrait être un amendement
éventuelles et surtout vue d'un projet
de loi final parfait c'est ce que les
ministres la forêt a déclaré en
commission parlementaire lorsque
questionné par madame thériault à savoir
est ce que vous allez remettre cette
disposition dans la loi la ministre s
est engagé à le faire donc plus de
professionnalisme mais je répète plus
d'argent dans le fonds de prévoyance ça
va pour les copropriétaires actuels
coûter plus cher mais ça aux côtés de
juste prix parce que des copropriétés
qui provisionne adéquatement leurs fonds
propres et ans ils vont faire des études
de fond croyances d'ailleurs c'est d'un
projet de loi 16 mai pour les côtés qui
sont en déficit d'environ d'avoir
accumulé décembre qu'ils savent aux
côtés de charles rythme et donc ce
serait quoi le bon pourcentage d'argent
à placer dans le fonds de prévoyance
en fait la seule loi la loi actuelle
prévoyant 1 5% du budget d'opération
devrait mettre minimalement en font une
croyance qui ont découvert 25 ans plus
tard c'est que c'est généralement
suffisant pour faire face aux
réparations majeures donc l'étude va
établir les sommes requises
on parle plus pour cent atteints gens
parlent de faire une étude qui voit des
termes et des besoins du bâtiment
tout dépendra son bâtiment inondé les
bâtiments spécifiques chaque syndicat va
devoir faire une étude de fond croyances
pour établir ma cadre du budget
d'opération laissant les deux versions
foudroyant ce qui va faire l'étude
ça devrait d'enfants des gens qui sont
spécialistes là dedans il ya déjà des
archers des architectes des ingénieurs
des technologues qui font ce genre
d'étude sur une marche
alors tous avec déterminé par voie
réglementaire qui seront qui seront les
professeurs appropriée en cette matière
et quel coût et de faire cette étude
près forcément eu un coût mais c'était
de live rapidement rentabilisé parce que
plus on intervient en amont sur les
travaux - là coûte cher donc finalement
voir un guide et surtout pour les
acheteurs contre hama ce qui se fait sur
le marché parce que si on dit on achète
un condo à la veuve
on sait pas trop trop si le bâtiment
était bien entretenu s'il faut envoyer
ans c'est suffisant pour avoir un
véritable kit pour les acheteurs hélas
les fonds de prévoyance actuellement est
ce que c'est la majorité qui sont mal
financée d'ailleurs je sais que faites
un sondage et qui surgit quelques années
sur l'état des fonds croyances et aussi
parce qu un saint ce cas sur deux les
tarnais suffisance de fond lorsque les
grands travaux de vsphere oui pour ça
veut dire cotisation spéciale et parfois
ses cotisations spéciales sont au delà
de la capacité de payer de certains
copropriétaires dont on parle il faut 10
15 25 milliards de cotisations spéciales
par copropriétaires lorsqu'on fait face
aux grands travaux dans des copropriétés
alors avec la nouvelle loi on pourrait
provisionner un fonds de prévoyance mais
sur un certain temps s'ils manquent
d'argent on peut professeur faire ça
d'un coup siècle ben c'est sûr c'est à
dire de deux dissidents dans le fond les
apports financiers des copropriétaires
et le projet de loi pour faire atterrir
en douceur
c'est conscient de fond croyances il ya
le fond d'auto-assurance également passe
aussi nouveau dans le projet doit 141
qu'il quitte qui est en face on veut
forcer les syndicats à mettre de côté
les sommes qui correspondent aux
franchises d'assurances mail
heureusement de des franchisés sont
inscrits m'ont vendu à 25 50 voire 100
meilleurs parcours propriété et le sacré
d'un fonds serait financé pour de
nombreuses copropriétés la copropriété
populaire de nos jours n'est ce pas
c'est devenu vraiment types de
propriétés très prisée en fait si le
mode d'accession à la propriété dans les
centres urbains parce que justement on
commence à marquer terrain donc on va
construire sur une base d'élévation et
forcément c'est de la korité du viscos
développe et met en jeu le coeur merci
beaucoup on va surveiller de près
l'évolution des travaux de cette
commission sur le projet doit